hey hey you would you like a balloon
don't be shy
I'm matpat the YouTube clown and we've
got a whole circus down here with memes
and ponds and Furies galore oh we all
your eyes down here yes we do and when
you're down here you'll fear eyes -
you'll be erisa do you fear eyes dude
hello Internet welcome to film theory so
after last week's emoji movie episode I
figured we'd dial it back this week and
talk about a film that's a little less
scary
it's chapter one oh sure it hides the
fact that it's a two-parter until its
final moments and everyone gets super
excited about it
I do it and people complain about
clickbait double standards here guys
double standards huh just like the FTC
guidelines were talking about last week
so semantics regardless I loved this
movie you see I was never a big fan of
the original 1990 version don't get me
wrong Tim Curry is one of my favorite
actors of all time and can do literally
no wrong in my eyes but popping
blood-filled Blues in the library is
that scary especially because you can
see the actors responding to the popping
but they're not supposed to sense what's
going on it's just it's just rim G and I
should know a thing or two about cringe
will you go to prom with me Medina
anyway between the imaginative scares
crappy imagery and solid acting this
reboot had it all well maybe not it all
since the original novel also has a big
celebratory preteen sexual Rob for the
losers Club after defeating anywise yeah
yeah no joke apparently in addition to
being the master of horror Stephen King
wanted to be the master of the awkward
chapter well after eating how bill been
bev richie eddie mike and stan show
their affection for each other in the
sewers of Derry after defeating an evil
clown mission accomplished Steve at any
rate for as much as I loved it y'all
know that I couldn't go see it without
getting the old furious tears of grease
and I had a thought towards the end of
the movie how are these kids able to
survive all of penny wises attacks
Pennywise successfully targets other
children like Georgie and Betty rips end
but even when alone with individual
members of the losers Club Pennywise
can't make the kill I mean obviously as
main characters the easy explanation
here is that they all have flawed arm
but after doing my homework into it and
the rest of Stephen King's work I found
my answer the losers Club isn't just a
group of ordinary kids all of these kids
shines
no not like a giant supernatural crab
though come to think of it that's more
of Penny wisest domain no boy for those
of you who don't know how the rest of it
goes you are in for a weird ride know
what I mean to say is that these kids
shine like Danny Torrance from another
Stephen King work you've probably heard
of The Shining if it's been a minute
since you saw that movie let me help you
out
shining means having some level of
psychic ability in the shining Danny's
shine gives him the ability to
communicate with others telepathically
and interact with supernatural beings
he's basically bran from Game of Thrones
but with more emotions and more working
legs and when you look at the evidence
it's pretty clear that the losers club
also has this psychic shine ability so
in today's episode I'm gonna break it
down for you like a crazy man with an
axe
here's mad Pat now some people might
think this theory is over before it even
begins
since nobody in it references psychic
powers the Overlook Hotel or the fact
that the moon landing didn't happen you
know all those things that are normally
associated with the shining but here's
the thing Stephen King puts Marvel and
Pixar to shame with how interconnected
his universe is he was doing a dark
connected universe before the dark
connected universe began and also
apparently after it ended - here are
just a few ways it connects to the wider
Stephen King averse the losers Club is
mentioned by name in his novel
dreamcatcher Mike Hanlon one of the
club's members grows up to be the town
librarian and dairy which we see in
another King novel insomnia and somebody
even sees glowing clown eyes in a storm
drain in the Tommyknockers but we're not
just talking about a general shared
universe here it has direct connections
to the shining through one man dick
hallorann chef of the Overlook Hotel in
a scene in it chapter one Bend recap
some of the past tragedies that have
happened to Derry one of them is a fire
that happened at the black spot an
african-american nightclub that burned
down during a past visit from Pennywise
in 1962 one of the people who survived
that fire dick hallorann in fact dick
actually saves Mike Hanlan's father from
dying in that fire and here's the best
part
dick possesses the shine himself in fact
throughout the shining he teaches Danny
about the gift and communicates
telepathically with him
so having a character with psychic
abilities serve as the bridge between
the two stories not only shows us that
we're working in the same universe but
also that the ability to shine is
definitely something that exists in the
world of its so what kind of indication
do we have that the kids in the losers
Club actually shine we don't actually
see too much of it in this first movie
but you will definitely start to see it
drop up in it chapter 2 because the
clues are definitely there in the novel
you see in the story of it all the kids
grow up to be unusually successful but
they all have to return to Derry to once
again face Pennywise and finish him off
for good bill as an adult fights it
through a psychic battle of wills known
as the ritual of Jude now this is gonna
sound really weird if you haven't read
the book they actually scratch that it's
pretty weird even if you have read the
book but bill is instructed by an
interdimensional turtle yeah a turtle
that the only way to defeat it for good
is to engage in this ritual and use his
imagination as a psychic counterbalance
to its powers the battle is done
entirely telepathically now look at the
description that dick hallorann uses
when he's describing what the shine is
my grandmother and I could hold
conversations some of you still might
not believe which is dangerous because
belief is what keeps Pennywise from
eating you nonetheless you might be
thinking that this theory has a few
holes in it kinda like dick hallorann at
the end of the shining boom ching let's
try to plug those holes in with more
evidence shall we towards the end of the
novel it Mike Hanlon is in the hospital
far away from the rest of the losers
Club horde descending into its lair you
would think Mike would be safe but in
actuality there's someone in his room
waiting to kill him bill again from deep
in the sewers suddenly senses that mike
is in trouble and instructs the group to
quote send him our power at which point
the club rocks hands and sends Mike
psychic energy to fight off his attacker
like a Goku sized spirit Bob it's not
just Bill the novel clearly states that
Bev feels something leave them and go to
my quote from page 1083 yeah in case II
didn't know it is a long book so
something rudra wrong bill said Mike I
feel it too Ben said send him our power
bill cried then felt something go out
from them and toward Mike end quote and
then a few sentences later Mike push the
call button in his hands you could hear
it ringing at the nurse's station down
the hall but no one came with a kind of
hellish second sight he understood that
the nurses were sitting around down
there hearing his call bell but not
responding Mike suddenly felt power wash
into him some primitive power that
crammed his body like bolts so again
we're seeing references to these kids
having a quote unquote second sight and
feeling psychic power transitioning
between them and during the ritual of
Jude Bill isn't the only one
telepathically communicating with it Ben
actually begins the battle by reading
its mind quote it was squealing and
mewling and Ben became quite sure he was
hearing sounds it made twice telepathic
he thought I'm reading its mind
end quote so that's Bill Bev Mike and
now Ben all with some sort of reference
to telepathy or psychic ability we can
even include Ritchie in this because he
also engages in the telepathic ritual of
Jude and communicates with Bill
psychically during that moment of the
novel we even see that Ritchie actually
shares a psychic connection with other
members of the town specifically an
Irish police officer named now it's not
important for us to go into just know
that it happens anyway very long and
very complicated story short the psychic
connection is shared between all of the
members of the losers Club its strongest
with Bill but all the others have
instances where they feel or sense
something telepathically which begs the
question why why these kids what's the
probability of having so many shiners in
the same town let alone the same group
well there's actually a pretty clear
explanation the shine tends to
show up in kids were victims of abuse in
the shining Jack Torrance Danny's father
was a violent alcoholic we hear in the
movie and repeatedly in the novel that
he dislocated Danny's arm during one of
his drunken rages and his wife Wendy's
description of it as just an accident
certainly makes it sound like there's
either a lot more there or that it's
happened before came home about three
hours late so he wasn't exactly in the
greatest mood that night this particular
occasion has been just too much also
notice that Danny's psychic ability
which he's nicknamed Tony it's weird but
don't get confused there Tony doesn't
appear until after this traumatic
accident at the hands of his dad in the
shining sequel dr. sleep yep there's a
sequel today's episode is just full of
surprises we find out that when dick
hallorann was a child he was sexually
and physically abused by his grandfather
it doesn't seem like a coincidence that
two characters who are confirmed to have
the shine were both victims of childhood
violence now let's go through the losers
Club Bill is bullied for his stutter
Bev is sexually abused by her creepy
father Ritchie's abuse isn't explicit in
the movie but he actually suffers from
parental neglect which is the reason why
he feels the need to constantly keep
talking and be funny he doesn't want
people to abandon him Eddie is the
victim of his mother's munchausen
syndrome by proxy being diagnosed with
fake ailments to make him think he's
sick so that she can control his life
Mike is called an outsider in the most
recent movie but the old miniseries a
novel make it pretty clear that Mike is
the victim of racial slurs and racially
motivated violence stan is bullied for
being Jewish and Ben is bullied for
being overweight in the original movie
and for being the new kid in the reboot
given the fact that all these people
share a history of trauma and exhibit
some level of telekinetic ability isn't
it possible that shining is developed as
a coping mechanism so there you have it
a shining theory not rooted in
moon-landing conspiracies but so what
even if the kids in it are like dick and
Danny and the shining does any of that
really matter well yeah actually it does
absolutely it does it might not just be
that the kids have the same power it
might
also mean that they're fighting the same
evil considering that it is a
shapeshifter and is really just a
manifestation of evil energy from the
multiverse why couldn't it be the evil
at the Overlook Hotel a deeper look into
this is probably a theory for another
day but let's just do some quick
detective work to talk about how the
evil operates in both the shining and
it's towards the end of the shining jack
crazy and completely consumed by the
spirits of the Overlook Hotel is locked
in the pantry by his wife Wendy near the
end of it we catch up with adult Henry
Bowers who's gone completely crazy and
is locked in a mental asylum in both
instances a ghost appears to the men for
Jack it's Delbert Grady if the former
caretaker of the hotel who killed his
family and wants Jack to do the same for
Henry Bowers it's his old henchman belch
who wants Henry to go kill the losers
Club both jack in the shining and Henry
in it are imprisoned but their
respective ghostly visions say that they
can get him out in exchange for the
respective men committing murder and we
know in both of these instances that
they aren't hallucinations because in
both situations the ghosts provide them
with a physical murder weapon the
croquet mallet for Jack and the
Switchblade for Henry it's the exact
same tactic with the exact same goal
maybe it's not so much that Pennywise
can't kill people who shine but rather
just knows how dangerous people who
shine can be because they can use the
ritual of chewed by employing Jack
Torrance to kill his son Danny and Henry
Bowers to kill the losers Club the
threat to it is effectively wiped out
and it can continue to terrorize and
feast on others who are less psychically
inclined and when you consider that all
these Stephen King's stories share a
universe does it have to stop there I
couldn't evil energy that creates
Pennywise possess a dog like in Cujo or
create a bunch of pet zombies like in
Pet Sematary
or convince a girl to murder her
classmates in Cary if Pennywise is a
shapeshifter that opens the door for it
to be the evil in pretty much every
Stephen King story ever a clown a hotel
an evil car or anything else it might
even mean that Pennywise doesn't go into
hibernation maybe he just moves
somewhere else in those thirty years
between appearances and dairy but that's
all speculation that might lead to a
video another day for now remember it's
all just a theory a film theory and this
theory is battery acid and it'll melt
your face off
you'll subscribe to you'll subscribe to
you'll subscribe to subscribe - you'll
subscribe - you'll subscribe - subscribe
do y'all subscribe galz subscribe